PROFESSOR: So there's two things
that we need to do in
today's lecture.
The first is to finish up our
discussion of deontology,
which was necessarily
quite rushed.
We're trying to do Kant
in roughly a lecture.
But I do want to get to the
end of that discussion.
And the second, which will allow
you to use your clickers
and express your opinions, is to
talk through the structure
of Judy Thomson's trolley
problem paper.
So you recall from last lecture
that our goal in
understanding the very brief
selection from Kant's
Groundwork to the Metaphysics of
Morals that we read was to
try to make sense of the three
claims that he makes in the
first book, first chapter,
of that volume.
And those claims, to which
I've now added some
underlining, are
the following.
The first is the claim that in
order to have moral worth, an
action needs to be
done from duty.
And the distinction that Kant
is making there is the
distinction between doing
something in keeping with
duty, that is, something that
conforms to what morality
demands of you, and doing
something not merely in
keeping with, but
also from duty.
And Kant's picture is that the
moral worth of an action is
determined not merely by it
being in keeping with duty.
That's a necessary but not
a sufficient condition.
What determines the moral worth
of an action is that it
be done in keeping with duty
for the sake of being in
keeping with duty, that is,
it be done from duty.
The second thing that Kant says,
the second proposition
which he seeks to defend in the
Groundwork, is the claim
that an action done
from duty--
that's the thing we were talking
about in the first
claim-- an action done from duty
has its moral worth not
in the purpose that is to be
attained by it, not in what
the Greeks would call its telos,
its goal, its aim, but
rather in the maxim according
to which the action is
determined.
That is, what determines the
morality of the action on the
Kantian picture is the
description under which the
action is performed.
Now, a number of you came to
office hours yesterday, and we
had a rather lively discussion
of how it is that one goes
about determining what things
count as maxims. And I
encourage those of you who are
interested in that question to
take an ethics course, where
you can work through Kant's
writings on this question
in more detail.
For the purpose of our class,
all we need to hold on to is
the simple idea that what Kant
is interested in here are acts
under a description, and that
that description is going to
have to satisfy a certain
sort of test, as we'll
find out in a moment.
So that's Kant's second claim.
Kant's third claim is that duty,
which is the central
notion to deontology --
deon, duty is at the core
of deontology --
duty is "the necessity of an
action done out of respect for
the law." And the idea here is
that not only do you need to
act with the goal of conforming
to the law in mind,
not only do you need to do so
in a way that you articulate
your actions as falling under
that norm, but you do so
because you take the moral law
to be morally binding upon
you, because you recognize that
it is what rationality
demands of you.
The moral law turns out be the
law of governing your behavior
that you set for yourself
as a rational being.
It is the only aspect of your
behavior on the Kantian
picture that isn't determined
by the contingent forces of
the world around you.
It's determined by your
recognition of your role as
somebody capable of binding
themselves to a law that they
themselves set.
So as I said, the reason we were
interested in these three
principles was to get to Kant's
famous formulation of
the categorical imperative.
And we closed lecture last time
by meeting one member of
the categorical imperative
family in response to Kant's
question: "What sort of law
can it be, the thought of
which must determine the will
without reference to any
expected effects so that the
will can be called absolutely
good without qualification?"
Kant sets himself, as I said,
this cliffhanger of a question,
and answers it with
the first member of the
categorical imperative family.
It's the will's "universal
conformity of its actions to
law as such." Only thereby,
says Kant, can one act
autonomously and not
heteronomously.
What does it mean to act
autonomously as opposed to
heteronomously?
Let's look at the words:
autonomous, heteronomous.
You'll notice that they both
have here the word
nomos, that is, law.
And they distinguish the law to
which you're subjected by
saying that in one case, it's
an auto-nomos, and in the
other case, it's
a hetero-nomos.
Auto-nomos.
What could that be?
Let's think of other
words where we
have this prefix auto-.
How about automobile?
What's an automobile?
An automobile is something
that is self-propelled.
It is propelled by
its own strength.
To act autonomously, on Kant's
picture, is to act on the
basis of a law that you
yourself have imposed.
You are auto-nomos, subject to
a law that comes from within.
By contrast, what is it
to be hetero-nomos?
Well, what is it to
be heterosexual?
What it is to be heterosexual is
to be attracted sexually to
individuals that have a
different gender than you do.
So what is it to be
hetero-nomos?
It's to have law given unto you
that comes from outside of
you, that comes from something
different from you.
So Kant's picture is that
autonomy, self-lawgiving, is
possible only when the law
to which you conform your
behavior comes not from the
contingencies of the world,
but comes from within.
In this way, Kant is concerned
with the same sorts of
questions that Epictetus
and Boethius are.
Both of them are profoundly
concerned with how it is that
human freedom is possible, and
Kant's picture is that human
freedom becomes possible when
you govern your actions on the
basis of what do you yourself
decide to be, norms that you
want to conform to.
In particular, when you conform
your actions to the
categorical imperative, which
says, in the formulation that
we see at the beginning of this
section, that you should
"never act in such a way that
you cannot also will that your
maxim"--there's your maxim
again--"should become a
universal law." When you act in
such a way that you don't
take the contingencies of
your situation into
consideration--but rather that
you think of yourself as one
among any number of beings who
in your situation would do
exactly what you do--only then
do you become free of the
contingencies of circumstance.
So the picture is that in some
ways, by stepping beyond the
bounds of the contingent
features of your experience,
by stepping beyond the bounds of
yourself, you thereby gain
freedom from the contingencies
of the world around you.
And Kant suggests that if you
take this on has a picture,
you will come to see that it
conforms with the rules of
rationality.
So, he says, suppose you're
confronted with a very
particular case of an act that
you want to perform under a
particular maxim.
The maxim you set for yourself
is, "when I make a promise and
it's going to be a pain in the
neck for me to keep that
promise, I'll break
that promise.
That is, the maxim is, it's
OK for me to make lying
promises."
And Kant asks, suppose that
you made, under that
description, a promise that
you didn't intend to keep.
Can that maxim and
be universalized?
Well, he says, suppose
that it were.
Suppose everybody, when they
made promises, did so only
with the thought that they
would keep them when
convenient and not when they
were inconvenient.
Were that to happen, says Kant,
there would be no such
thing as reliable promising.
Why?
Well, because promises
are like balconies.
We don't step out on a balcony
if there's a good chance that
the balcony will break when
we step out on it.
And we don't step out on
promises, on commitments that
others make to us, unless we are
close to certain that that
promise will be preserved.
So, says Kant, since the
practice of promising would
break down if everybody who
found it convenient made lying
promises, it is not in keeping
with what the moral law
demands of us that we make
a lying promise.
And, Kant suggests, this
framework can be extended to
all the kinds of duties
that there are.
There are, suggests Kant, two
categories of obligation that
we have towards ourselves
and to others.
We have duties to ourself and
duties to other people.
And, in addition, says Kant, we
have perfect duties, things
that we need always to do, and
imperfect duties, things that
we need sometimes to do.
In all four of these cases, says
Kant in the reading that
we did, we can see that the
categorical imperative gives
us guidance as to whether
an action
under a maxim is permitted.
The action under the maxim is
going to be permitted if it
can be universalized,
and it's going to be
prohibited if it can't.
So if we ask this question, is
it all right to make lying
promises, and we say to ourself,
suppose everybody
made lying promises, we discover
that the act of lying
promises is prohibited by the
categorical imperative,
because it can't be
universalized.
Suppose we ask the question,
"is it OK to commit suicide
when feeling frustrated with
the world?" And Kant says,
suppose everybody did that.
The practice, the convoluted
argument would break down,
because there would be nobody
enough to kill themselves.
So goes the argument.
Suppose we ask ourselves whether
we have a duty to
cultivate our talent?
Kant says: suppose nobody
cultivated their talents.
The world in which we live would
be one in which nobody
would want to live.
And consequently, we have a
moral obligation to do.
Finally, he asks, "do we have an
obligation to give money to
those in need?" And asks again,
what would happen if it
were a universal law
that nobody gave
money to those in need?
And again we discover a
breakdown of an ordered world
in which we want to survive.
Now, there's room for
questioning--
in fact, there's room for
questioning all four of these
derivations, though it's
generally accepted that the
lying promise derivation is the
most effective of them.
But let's look instead at what
Kant says about them, if it
were to turn out that these
derivations worked.
Kant says, "these are some of
the many actual duties whose
derivation from the single
principle above is clear."
"It's clear" is a bit of a
stretch, but we can see how
that derivation would go.
What does this tell
us about morality?
Kant says it tells us that when
we take an act and try to
determine whether it's moral,
we need to check to see
whether we're making an
exception for ourselves.
When we act, we need to be able
to will that a maxim of
our actions become
a universal law.
When we transgress, says Kant,
we don't will that our maxim
should become a universal law,
but rather that the opposite
of this maxim should remain
a law universally.
So suppose you like to sit in
the last two rows of this
classroom, even though you
arrive not late to class.
Can you will that this become
a universal law, or is this
something that has works for you
only if others are willing
to sit further in so that
there's room for
people on the stairs?
Kant would say that the moral
law demands of you that you
move inward, because you're
sitting in those last two
rows, despite your not late
arrival, depends on other
people doing something
different.
Stealing depends
on other people
respecting the laws of properly.
Your not paying the toll on the
subway depends on other
people paying the toll so that
there's enough money to keep
up the subway.
When you make an exception for
yourself, says Kant, you
violate the moral law.
And we'll return to this at the
opening of our discussion
of political philosophy,
when we talk
about prisoner's dilemma.
Now, I mentioned in passing that
you had met one member of
the categorical imperative
family, that you had met
what's sometimes called the
formula of the universal law:
that one should "act only in
accordance with that maxim
through which you can, at the
same time, will that it become
a universal law."
Kant put the categorical
imperative four different ways
for a number of reasons.
One of which, he says, it that
in certain cases, it's easier
to see how to apply the
categorical imperative if we
frame it in a slightly
different way.
And I want to introduce you to
the other three, largely
because the second of these is
going to play a central role
in the second half of
today's lecture.
So Kant claims that it is
equivalent to saying that "you
should act only in such a way
that you can will your maxim
to be universal" to say that
"you should act so as to treat
humanity, whether in your own
person or that of any other,
in every case as an end, and
never merely as a means only."
Do not use yourself as a means
to an end, and do not use
others in your interactions
with them merely as means.
Treat humanity and all others
as ends in themselves.
Equivalent to that, says Kant,
is the formula of autonomy,
which we've already talked
about recently.
"Act so that through your
maxims, you could be a
legislator of universal laws."
Act in such a way that you are
self-lawgiver with respect to
rules that reason endorses.
And finally, a rather
complicated notion, sometimes
called the kingdom of ends
formulation, "act in
accordance with the maxims of a
member giving universal laws
for a possible kingdom of
ends,"--a harmonious society
in which everybody exists
according to the
laws that you give.
As I said, we have only about an
hour's worth of Kant, so we
won't focus on the third
and the fourth.
But I do want to call your
attention to the formula of
humanity, because as I said,
it's going to play a central
roll in Judy Thomson's ultimate
diagnosis of what may
be going on in our intuitions
about trolley cases.
So let me close the discussion
of Kant by trying to connect
it back to the mini-unit
of which it is a part.
You'll recall that we began this
section of the course on
the seventeenth, that is, last
Thursday, with thinking about
consequentialism as
a moral theory.
And the question that I want to
ask is: what is there that
is common to the two concrete
moral theories that we've
taken a look at the beginning
of this unit?
We've looked so far as some
of the differences between
consequentialism on
the one hand and
deontology on the other.
But I think it's important, in
moving on to some of their
practical applications,
to think about what
they have in common.
And what they have in common
is that both teleology,
consequentialism, utilitarianism
in the
particular form that we found
it--and deontology prohibit
first-person exceptionalism.
Kant says: my desire may serve
at bases for willed actions
only if I can, at the same,
coherently will that others in
similar circumstances would
act in a way that I am
choosing to act.
I'm only allowed to do things
that I'm going to assume other
people are also allowed to do.
And Bentham, quoted in Mill,
Bentham, the great grandfather
of utilitarianism, says,
"everyone is to count for one,
no one for more than one."
Mill, in his greatest
happiness principle, speaks of
the happiness of all, not the
happiness from the subjective
perspective.
So the challenge of morality is
that of viewing the world
not from the stance of your own
needs as the most central
set of needs in the world, but
rather from the perspective of
your own needs as one set of
needs among those of six
billion equally sentient
beings.
Now the problem for morality is
that the tendency towards
first person exceptionalism, the
tendency to take one's own
needs as more important than the
needs of anybody else is
perhaps the most widespread
and pervasive
psychological bias.
And when we get to the unit on
political philosophy after
March break, we'll talk about
ways in which social
structures are put into place
to help deal with
this sort of tension.
Even in the passages from Mill
that we read for last
Thursday, Mill talks about what
sorts of attitudes it's
important to cultivate in
individuals so that they begin
to view the world from
a moral perspective.
In the selections that we read
from book ten of Aristotle's
Nicomachean Ethics, Aristotle
asked, in what way should
society be structured
to make it easy for
people to act morally?
And in some ways, the question
with which we're going to
close the course--how does
rational versus nonrational
persuasion work, what are the
roles of literary as opposed
to argumentative representations
of the good
life--is a version of this
dilemma, operationalized.
How is it, given an inevitable
human tendency to take one's
needs as more important than
others, how is it possible to
structure society in
such a way that the
needs of all are met?
So that's what I want to
say by way of the Kant.
And in the remainder of lecture,
I want to ask you to
take out your clickers
and enjoy the ride.
So as you know, the paper which
we read for today is a
great and intricate paper by the
philosopher Judith Jarvis
Thomson written in the mid-1980s
in response to an
earlier paper by another
mid-century woman philosopher,
Philippa Foot.
And what Philippa Foot and Judy
Thomson are interested in
in these papers is a systematic
exploration of a
number of cases which seem to
evoke, in most subjects,
pretty powerful intuitions about
what the right thing to
do is, but which seem to
adduce intuitions the
explanation for which is
hard to systematize.
So as you know well, the
first case, which we'll
call trolley driver--
there's the driver--
is this.
There's a trolley, hurtling down
a track, in such a way
that going to kill
five people.
But it turns out that there is
a second track onto which the
trolley could be
diverted, where
there is only one person.
And the question is this.
The trolley driver is
driving the trolley.
It's heading towards the five
people in such a way that he
is going to kill the five.
Should he, is he morally
required to, morally
prohibited from, or perhaps
neither prohibited nor
required but rather just
permitted, to turn the trolley
onto the track where there
is only the one?
Now notice that though this
is framed as an idealized
problem, the diversion of
threat is something that
decision-makers face
all the time.
Suppose there is an airplane
that has become incapacitated,
that's falling in such a way
that it's going to land on a
large city, and it would be
possible to divert the plane
so that it falls on a less
populated area instead.
Suppose that there is an illness
which is taking the
lives of many people, but if one
quarantines those who are
ill, causing that number
to die, the rest of the
population will be spared.
In case after case, we face
dilemmas with roughly the
structure of trolley.
So though these cases are
idealized, in the sense that
we're granting ourselves that
we know with certainty what
the outcomes will be, it is, I
think, not a useless exercise,
even if our concern is
real-world morality, to think
through what the right thing
to do is in these cases.
So let's start with the case of
the trolley driver, driver
of the trolley.
The trolley is heading down the
track in such a way that
the driver will, with the
trolley, kill five people if
he doesn't turn it.
He faces the choice of turning
the trolley onto the track
where there is the one.
Question.
Is it morally mandatory for him
to turn a trolley from the
five to the one?
Is it morally permitted, but not
morally mandatory, for him
to turn the trolley from
the five to the one?
Or is it morally prohibited for
him to turn the trolley
from the five to the one?
OK.
So let's see how the
numbers come out.
I'm going to write these down,
because we're going to need
them for later.
So 7% of you, very, very small
number, think that it's
morally prohibited for him
to turn the trolley.
The vast majority of you, close
to two thirds, think
that it's morally permitted, but
not morally mandatory, for
him to turn the trolley.
And about 30% of you, roughly
a third, think that he is
morally required to
make that turn.
Case number two.
Transplant.
You're running a hospital.
Five people show up at the
hospital, all of them destined
to die, because one needs a
lung, and one needs a heart,
and one needs a kidney, and
one needs a liver, and one
needs a brain.
So they're all going to die,
and you are the doctor.
And into the emergency room
walks a perfectly healthy
young man who has a heart and
a lung and a liver and a
kidney and a really good,
active brain.
And if you were to chop up that
man and give his parts to
the five suffering individuals,
you could save
the five at the cost
of the one.
Question.
For the doctor, is it A, morally
mandatory to chop up
the healthy man to save the
five, B, morally permitted but
not morally mandatory to chop
up the healthy man, or C,
morally prohibited to chop
up the healthy man?
So let's see how numbers
so come out.
So.
85% of you think it is morally
prohibited to cut up the one
to save the five.
9% of you think it is
morally permitted,
but not morally mandatory.
And 6% of you--
off to med school--
think that it is morally
mandatory to chop up the
healthy man.
So what's going on here?
So Philippa Foot, who was the
person who initially presented
this juxtaposition,
has a hypothesis.
And her hypothesis is this.
That in the trolley driver
case, the choice that the
driver faces is between killing
one and killing five.
Whereas in the transplant case,
the choice that the
doctor faces is between
killing one and
letting five die.
And if we were to graph these
on what I'll call the
bad-o-meter, which tells us how
bad things are, we would
discover that letting five die
is bad, but killing one is
worse, and killing five
is even worse.
And so this seems to give us the
answer that since killing
five is worse than killing
one, then in the trolley
driver case, it's OK for him to
turn the trolley, but since
killing one is worse than
letting five die, then in the
doctor case, it's not OK
to chop up the one man.
Because in the doctor case, you
have to kill once to save
five, whereas in the trolley
case, the driver has to kill
one in order not to kill five.
And that seems to accord
pretty well with your
intuitions.
93% of you think it's permitted,
in the trolley
case, to turn the trolley,
whereas only 14% of you think
it's permitted in the doctor's
case to kill the one.
So it looks like this
bad-o-meter is pretty well
capturing the intuition
of those
of you in this classroom.
And in fact, empirical studies
that have been done on
thousands and thousands of
people throughout the world
suggest that your intuitions are
pretty much in line with
the intuitions of most.
But there's a problem.
Case number three, trolley
bystander.
Here's Jim.
Poor Jim.
Really bad luck.
First he shows up in this Latin
American town, and he's
supposed to shoot
some Indians.
Now here he is, next to a
trolley which is hurtling down
a track, about to kill
five people.
But here there is, in the middle
of the track, a switch
that if Him turns will cause the
trolley to kill the one.
Question.
For Jim, the bystander, is it
morally mandatory for him to
turn the trolley so that instead
of the trolley hitting
the five, it hits the one?
Is it morally permitted, but not
morally mandatory for him
to turn the trolley?
That's answer two.
Or is it morally prohibited for
him to turn the trolley?
See how those numbers
come out.
OK.
And here are your numbers.
15, 70, 15.
These are very, very similar to
the distribution of answers
that you gave in the
driver case.
In the driver case, 63% of you
thought it was morally
permitted, whereas here
70% of you think
it's morally permitted.
In the driver case,
30% of you thought
it was morally mandatory.
Here slightly fewer
of you think it's
morally mandatory, 15%.
And in the driver case, 7% of
you thought it was prohibited.
Here 15% of you think it's
morally prohibited.
So there's a little change,
but not a lot of change.
Here's the problem.
Remember that in Foot's analysis
of the case, we knew
that letting five die was a
little bit bad, that killing
one was worse, and
that killing five
was worse than that.
Trolley driver faced the choice
of killing one versus
killing five.
In transplant, you face the
choice of killing ones versus
letting five die.
But what's going on in
the bystander case?
Well, in the bystander case,
Jim, Jim of the bad luck,
faces a choice between killing
one, diverting the trolley
onto the track in such a way
that Jim kills that guy--or
letting five die.
Letting the trolley hit the five
that it's going to hit
inevitably.
But in contrast to the doctor
case, where 85% of you thought
it was prohibited to kill the
one in order to save the five
who would otherwise die, in this
case, 85% of you think
it's at least permitted to kill
the one in order to let
the five die.
Let me do that again for you.
85% of you--watch the
bad-o-meter--think that it
goes the other way.
Now what's going on?
We thought we had a solution
to the problem.
The solution to the problem that
differentiated transplant
from trolley driver was the
distinction between killing
and letting die.
And all of a sudden, there's a
whole bunch of you who seem to
be saying about bystander that
letting five die is worse than
killing one.
You must think that, or you
wouldn't think that it's
morally, at least, permitted for
him to turn the trolley.
Moreover, stuff gets
even worse.
Suppose that the hospital case
comes about as follows.
Five healthy individuals show
up at the hospitals, and a
doctor--either because he's
tired or because he wants to
get the insurance benefits of
which he is a beneficiary if
there are a lot of sick
patients in his
hospital--poisons the five who
show up, in such a way that
one of them needs a liver, one
of them needs a kidney, one of
them needs lungs, one of them
needs a heart, and one of them
needs a brain.
And so as a result of what that
man has done, these five
individuals will die.
And it's a few hours later,
and he thinks, "Oh!
I forgot about the categorical
imperative!
Shoot!
What am I going to do?" And up
shows a healthy individual,
and he thinks, "Oh, God, I've
got a solution, here, I can
chop him up.
Heart, lung, kidneys,
liver, brain, and I
can save the five.
OK."
Question.
For the doctor who has poisoned
the five individuals
who earlier showed up at the
hospital, who now faces the
option of saving their lives by
killing the one, is it A,
morally mandatory to chop up
the healthy man, B, morally
permitted, but not morally
mandatory, to chop up the
healthy man, or C, morally
prohibited to chop up the
healthy man?
And let's see how the
numbers come out.
All right.
So.
82%, 11%, 7%.
So your numbers here are almost
identical to what they
were in the original
doctor case.
There it was 6, 9, 85,
here it's 7, 11, 82.
Almost no difference.
But let's go back to
our bad-o-meter.
We are going to set aside the
killing and letting die
question, and just look at the
kill one versus kill five.
So we know from trolley
driver that killing
one is pretty bad.
But according to most of you,
according to you 93% of you,
killing five is worse
than killing one.
OK.
Poison doctor.
So here's what choice
the doctor faces.
He can kill five--
right?
He's poisoned them, and now
they're going to die.
Or he can kill just one--that
one healthy guy
who just showed up.
And then the other
five won't die.
82% of you told me that it was
better for him to kill five
than to kill one.
Let me show you this again,
on the bad-o-meter.
85% of you thought that it was
better for him to kill five
than to kill one.
So we have these two
super-duper, excellent
principles that seem to explain
what was going on in
the trolley case.
On the one hand, that killing
one was worse than letting
five die, and then all of a
sudden, bystander made us
think, oh no, we don't
have that intuition.
And then we have the intuition
that at least killing one was
better than killing five, and
the poison case made us
rethink that as well.
Now, there's an obvious issue
that maybe making the moral
difference here.
There's a temporal difference
between the killing of the one
and the killing of the
five happened.
And perhaps, says Thomson,
perhaps that's what explains
our intuition in the
doctor case.
Perhaps it is because the
killing of the five has become
a letting die, as the result of
time, that it's misleading
to describe this as a kill one
versus kill five case.
But the temporal is not going to
help us with the transplant
versus bystander case.
Those seem pretty clearly to be
both cases where one faces
the choice between killing
one and letting five die.
And whereas it seemed pretty
clear to most of you in
transplant that killing one was
worse than letting five
die, it seems pretty clear
that for most of you in
bystander, it's the
other way around.
So the trolley problem is the
problem raised by these
dancing arrows.
How is it that we systematize
our intuitions about killing
and letting die, given that they
appear to come apart in
these cases?
So Thomson suggests that whereas
the transplant case
gives us a choice between
killing one and letting five
die, as does bystander, there
is a potentially relevant
difference between them.
And that is that in the case of
transplant, you are using
the one as a means.
You're using the one as a way
to achieve the outcome of
saving the other five.
Whereas in bystander, when
you're diverting the trolley
onto the track where that one
individual is, you're not
using that individual as a
means, and--oh my goodness, I
told you we'd get back
to Kant, and we have!
What did Kant's formula
of humanity say?
Kant's formula of humanity
said, "so act as to treat
humanity, whether in your own
person or that of any other,
in every case as an end, and
never merely as a means only."
So maybe that's our solution.
Maybe the problem in bystander
is that since you're not
treating him as a means, it's
OK to kill the one.
Whereas in transplant, since
you are treating him as a
means, it's not OK to kill the
one, and consequently, you're
morally obliged to what
the five die.
Well, says Thomson, that
can't be quite right.
Suppose that you're Jim,
standing next to the trolley.
Trolley's on its usual path
to kill the five.
But here, instead of the
straight track on which the
one sits, there's a looped
track, and the one is in the
middle of the track in such a
way that if you divert the
trolley, it will hit him,
thereby saving the five.
Question.
In the case that Thomson calls
"loop," is it A, morally
mandatory to turn the
trolley, that's one.
B, morally permitted, but not
morally mandatory, or C,
morally prohibited?
So remember, trolley's
heading down the
track towards the five.
You're Jim.
The trolley's going to hit the
five, or you can divert the
trolley onto the track with the
one, and because the one
is there, you will cause
the trolley to stop.
OK?
So let's see how the numbers
come out on this.
OK.
So 68, 18, 14.
Not a lot of difference.
You've answered bystander in
loop in almost the same way
that you've answered all our
other trolley cases.
Generally the distribution
has been 15, 70, 15.
That was bystander.
Here it's 14, 68, 18.
But notice that in this case,
you were using the guy on the
loop track as a means!
You're using him as a
means to your end.
You're trying to stop the
trolley by using his body.
Kant didn't help us enough!
Restock.
Let's take stock again,
says Thomson.
Perhaps some of the work
is being done by
some notion of rights.
Perhaps what's going on in the
transplant case, the one where
you guys are not going to let
the doctor chop up the healthy
man, is that you would be
violating that man's rights.
And perhaps it's true that
"rights trump utility." That
is, that when somebody has a
right to bodily integrity,
that takes precedence over
the needs of the many.
The utilities of the five
that are going to saved.
And we'll close this lecture
with the final example, one
that's meant to test
that hypothesis.
And we'll begin next lecture
like by talking about some of
the reasons that people tend
to give this response.
So suppose now that instead
of the looping
track, there's a bridge.
And suppose that on
that bridge is our
fairly large gentleman.
And you are now faced with
the following dilemma.
The trolley's heading
down the track.
It's about to kill the five.
And here's how Jim the bystander
could stop it.
He could push the fat man off
the bridge, and thereby cause
the trolley to be stopped in
its tracks by his weight.
Question.
For the bystander in fat man,
is it morally mandatory to
push the fat man, morally
permitted but not morally
mandatory, or morally
prohibited to
push the fact man?
And let's take responses, and
I'll leave you with those
numbers and a remark about
them as our close.
So let's see whether we get any
shift in the fat man case.
My goodness!
That looks awfully different.
What is going on?
So remember, our classic
distribution is that we have
roughly 70% here, and no more
than 10% in the prohibited.
All of a sudden, 78% of you
think it's prohibited.
What's going on?
Cliffhanger!
We'll talk about
it on Tuesday.